rescued from the clutches of wouldbe
human traffickers in the Mexican state
of tamale lipas Mexican authorities
confirmed the release of 31 migrants who
were abducted while traveling toward
Mexico's border with the United States
on December 30th via the social media
platform X for months migration policy
experts and human rights activists have
warned over a worsening kidnapping
crisis in tamale lias especially near
the city of Rosa along the US Mexico
border in tamas Tam you have to consider
this is Tam lius and Rosa is the last
City before entering the United States
and in Rosa there are two criminal
Industries drug trafficking and human
trafficking migrants rights Advocates
say the best they can do is Warn
migrants and Asylum Seekers of the
risks migrant families have been
receiving warnings for a long time now
to be careful on the journey and to be
careful about who they speak
with 2023 saw a record number of people
attempting to cross the border from
Mexico into the US experts say where
there are migrants there are criminal
groups who seek to exploit them
according to the nonprofit group inside
crime migrant kidnappings here in Mexico
generate an estimated $20 million a year
for human traffickers though a majority
of migrants rescued on Wednesday are
from Venezuela authorities say they were
also individuals from at least four
other nationalities including Mex me
Honduras Ecuador and colia Manuel rapalo
Al jaaz Mexico
City make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer